after the colossal box-office flop that
was gods of Egypt the director alex
proyas has taken to Facebook to lash out
at the reviewers or deranged idiots as
he prefers to call them I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news update before
it was even released gods of Egypt was
known for whitewashing its cast fry us
mentions in his post that some people
formed an opinion about the movie before
it was even released and he doesn't like
that nothing confirms rampant stupidity
faster Prius starts off saying in all
caps than reading reviews of my own
movies I usually try to avoid the
experience but this one takes the cake
you see my dear fellow f Booker's I have
rarely gotten great reviews on any of my
movies apart from those by reviewers who
think for themselves and make up their
own opinions sadly those type of
reviewers are nearly all dead good
reviews often come many years after the
movie is opened I guess I have the knack
of rubbing reviewers the wrong way
always have this time of course they
have bigger access to grind they can rip
into my movie while trying to make their
mainly pale axes look so politically
correct by screaming whitewash like the
deranged idiots they all are like a
critic in a room with a movie no one has
even seen and they will not know what to
make of it because contrary to what a
critic should probably be they have no
personal taste or opinion because
they're basing their views on the status
quo none of them are brave enough to say
well I like it if it goes against
consensus therefore they are less than
worthless gods of Egypt currently has a
lowly score of 24 on metacritic have you
seen gods of Egypt to you an independent
reviewer who is able to think for
yourself like it or is it a big pile of
flaming crap let me know in the comments
or come and find me on Twitter I'm at
how not to draw thanks for watching and
for your gaming and entertainment news
keep it gamespot
you